this course will teach you how to
implement speech recognition in python
by building five projects
and it's easier than you may think
this course is taught by these two
amazing instructors hi everyone i'm
patrick
and i'm lisa patrick is an experienced
software engineer and menstrua is an
experienced data scientist and they're
both developer advocates at assembly ai
assembly ai is a deep learning company
that creates a speech-to-text api and
you'll learn how to use the api in this
course assembly ai provided a grant that
made this course possible
they also have a youtube channel where
they post weekly python and machine
learning tutorials
so here's the projects you'll learn to
build in this course so on the first
project we are going to learn how to
deal with audio data we are going to see
how to capture audio information from a
microphone and save it as a wave file in
the second project we are going to learn
how to do speech recognition on top of
this audio file that we have just
recorded using assembly ai's api on the
third project we are going to change
gears a little bit and start doing
sentiment analysis on iphone reviews
that you find on youtube on the fourth
project we are going to summarize
podcasts that we find online and build a
web app to show the results to users and
on the last project we are going to use
speech recognition in combination with
openai's api to make an app that can
answer users questions
i hope you are excited let's get started
alright so in this first part i teach
you some audio processing basics in
python so we briefly touch on different
audio file formats then we talk about
different audio signal parameters that
you should know then i show you how to
use the wave module to load and save a
wav file then i show you how you can
plot a wave signal then i also show you
how to do a microphone recording in
python and finally i also show you how
to load other file formats like mp3
files so let's get started so first of
all before we write some code let's talk
briefly about different audio file
formats so here i've listed three of the
most popular ones mp3 flag and wave mp3
is probably the most popular one that
you may know and this is a lossy
compression format so this means it
compresses the data and during this
process we can lose information
on the other hand flac is a loss less
compression format so it also compresses
the data but it allows to perfectly
reconstruct the original data and wave
is a uncompressed format so this means
it stores the data in an uncompressed
way so the audio quality here is the
best but also the file size is the
largest and wav is the standard for cd
audio quality so we focus on this in the
first part because it's actually very
easy to work with this in python because
we have a built-in wave module so we
don't have to install this
and now let's have a look at how we can
work with a wave audio file
by the way wave stands for wave form
audio format and before we start loading
some data let's talk about a few
parameters that we have to understand so
before we load our first wav file let's
understand a few parameters
so we have the number of channels this
is usually one or two so one is also
known as mono and two is stereo so this
is the number of the independent audio
channels for example two or stereo has
two independent channels and this means
it gives you the impression that the
audio is coming from two different
directions
then we have the sample width this is
the number of bytes for each sample so
this will get more clear later when we
have a look at an example
and then we have the frame rate which is
also known as the sample rate or sample
frequency and this is a very important
parameter so this means the
number of samples for each second
and for example you may have seen this
number a lot so this means
44
100 hertz or 44.1 kilohertz this is
usually the standard sampling rate for
cd quality
so this means we get 44
100 sample values in each second
and then we have the number of frames so
yeah this is the total number of frames
we get and then we have the values in
each frame and when we load this this
will be in a binary format but we can
convert this to integer values later
so now let's have a look at how to load
a
file so with the wav for wave module so
here i prepared a simple
wav file so this is five seconds long so
let's actually listen to this hi my name
is patrick and i'm a developer advocate
at assembly ai
and yeah here we also see a few
parameters already
so
now let's go back to the code and now
let's load this file so um for this we
create an object and we simply say
wave.open
then we have to give it the name so this
is called patrick.wave
and to read this we say we read this in
read binary
and now we can extract all these
different parameters for example let's
print the
let's say the
number of channels
and we get this by saying objects dot
get
n
channels
then we also want to print the sample
width so print the
sample width and we get this by saying
objects dot get
samp width
then let's print the
frame rate so print frame
rate and we get this by saying objects
dot get
frame rate
then what do we also want we also want
the number of frames so we print the
number of frames and then we say objects
dot get
and
not
and channels and frames and lastly um
let's also print the
um all the parameters so we can get all
the parameters at once by saying object
dot get
per params
and now let's print this so if we
run this so i say python wave example
dot pi
then we see we have only one channel so
this is a mono format we have a sample
width of two so we have two bytes for
each sample
then we have a frame rate of 16 000 and
a number of frames of 80 000
and here we also have all the parameters
as a
wave params object
so for example now we can calculate the
time of the audio
and we as i said the frame rate is the
number of samples per second
so if we get the whole
number of frames so the number of frames
or number of samples
divided
by the frame rate
then we get the time in seconds so now
if we print t
audio
and run this then we get 5.0 so five
seconds so this is the same that we see
here so this works
and now let's get the actual frames so
the frames equals objects dot
get
frames get
no sorry object dot read frames and then
we can give it the number of frames or
we can i think we can pass in -1 so this
will read
all frames
and let's for example so let's print the
type of this to see what this is
and then also print the type of frames
0
and then let's print the link of
frames
so
now let's run this
and
then we see this is a
um
bytes object
and
um so here we see class bytes and when
we extract the first byte then we see
this is a integer
and now the length of the frames object
is
160 000
so
this is not
the same as the number of frames so if
we have a look here the number of frames
is 80 000 but if we extract the length
here then this is twice as much
and if you listen carefully in the
beginning here i mentioned the sample
width this means we have two bytes per
sample
so now if we actually calculate this
divided by two
then again we get our 80 000
number of frames
and yeah this is how easily we can read
a wave um file and then we can work with
this and work with the frames
and now to
load or to save the data again we also
open let's call this object
new
equals and then we say wave dot open
then we can give it a new name let's say
patrick underscore new
dot wave and now we open this in right
binary mode
and now we can basically call all those
functions as setters and not as getters
so we say object new dot
set number of channels so this is only
one channel
then we say object new dot set sample
width this should be 2
object new dot
set frame rate this is
16 000 as a float
so these are all the parameters we
should set and then we can write the
frames by saying object new dot right
frames and then the
frames so here we have the
original frame so now basically we
duplicate the file so we write the
frames and what i forgot
so
when we are done with
opening this and reading all the
information we want we all should also
should call objects dot close
and then the same here so here we say
object new dot
close
and this will close the file objects and
yeah so now if we save this and run this
then now here we see we have the
duplicated file and if we run this hi my
name is patrick and i'm a developer
advocate at assembly ai then we see this
works and it has the same data in it so
yeah this is how to work with a wav file
and with the wave module so now let's
see how we can plot a wav file object
now plotting a wave signal is actually
not too difficult so for this we just
need to install matplotlib and numpy
then we import all the modules we need
so again we need wave then we need
matplotlib dot pi plot
s plt and then we import numpy
num
pi
s and p then again i want to read the
wav file so i say wave dot open and this
was
patrick dot wave in read binary mode
then i want to read all the parameters
that i need so i want to read the sample
frequency
and this is objects dot
get
frame rate
then i need the number of samples so
this is object dot get and frames
and then i also need the actual signal
so i call this signal dot wave equals
object dot read frames minus one
so all the frames and then i can say
object dot close
and then for example we can calculate
the number on the
the length of the signal in seconds so i
call this t
audio and if you remember this from the
first code so this is the
number of samples divided by the sample
frequency and now let's print the
t
audio
and save this and run this just as a
test so now we can run python plot audio
and we get 5.0
so this works so far
so
now um
i want to create the plot
so
this is a bytes object so we can create
a numpy array out of this very easily
so i call this um
signal
array equals and then we can use numpy
from buffer and here we put in the
signal
signal wave
and we can also specify a data type so
here i want to be to have this int 16
and
now we need an object for the x-axis or
the so the times axis
so we say times equals and here we use
the numpy linspace function
this gets zero as the start and the end
is the um length of the signal so this
is t audio or five seconds and then we
can also give this a number parameter
and the number is the number of samples
so
if you
remember so the
signal wave so here we basically get a
sample for each point in time
and now we want to plot this so we
create a figure so we say plt dot figure
and we give this a fix size of 15 by
five
then we say plt dot plot and we want to
plot the
times against the signal
array
then we simply give it um
a title plt dot title and let's call
this
audio signal
then i also want to say plt dot y
label
and the y label is the signal
wave
and the plt
x
label is um the time
time in seconds
and then we say p l t
x lim
and we limit this to be between zero and
t
audios for five seconds and then we say
plt dot show and this is all we need and
now if we run this
then this should open our plot and here
we have it so here we have our audio
signal plotted as a wave plot and this
is how easily we can do it with
matplotlib and the wave module now let's
learn how we can record with our
microphone and capture the microphone
input in python
so for this we use pi audio a popular
python library and this provides
bindings for port audio the cross
platform audio i o library so with this
we can easily play and record audio and
this works on linux windows and mac
and for each platform there's a slightly
different installation command that they
recommend so for example on windows you
should use this command on mac you also
have to install port audio first so if
you use homebrew then you can easily say
brew install port audio and then pip and
supply audio and on linux you can use
this command
so i already did this so here i'm on a
mac so i used brew install port audio
and then pip install pi audio and now i
can import this so i say import pi audio
and i also want to import wave to save
the recording later
then i want to set up a few parameters
so i say frames per buffer
and here i say
3200 so you can play around with this a
little bit then i specified the format
so the format equals pi audio dot
p
r
int 16
so this is basically the same that we
used here so here we use numpy in 16
and then here we have the pr in 16
then i also specify the number of
channels so here i say one so simply a
mono format
and then also the frame rate so the rate
here again i say sixteen thousand so
again you can use a different rate and
play around with this
then we create our pi audio object so we
say p equals pi
audio dot
pi
audio
then we create a stream object so we say
stream equals p dot open
and now we put in all the parameters so
we say format equals
format
then i need the channels so channels
equals channels
the rate equals the rate
we also want to capture the input so
input equals true
and lastly we say frames per buffer
equals frames per buffer
then we have our stream object so now we
can
print start
recording
and now we want to record for a number
of seconds so here i say five seconds
and then we store the frames and we
store this in a list object
and now we can iterate over and say for
i in range
and we start at zero and go until and
now we say rate divided by frames per
buffer
times the seconds
and then we convert this to a integer
not a float and with this we basically
record for five seconds
and then we read each chunk so we say
data
equals and then here we say stream dot
read and then we read the frames per
buffer
and then we say frames
dots append the data
so basically frames per buffer so this
means we read this many frames and at
once so with one iteration and now we
have it so now we can close everything
again so we can say stream dot stop
stream then we can also say stream dot
close
and we can say p
dot terminate
so now we have everything correctly shut
down and now we can for example save the
frames object again in a wav file so for
this i say
object equals wave dot open
and let's call this output dot wave and
in
right binary mode then we set all the
parameters so i set object set number of
channels this is the
channels parameter
objects dot set
sample width
this is the
this we get from p
dot get
sample size
of our format
then objects dot set frame rate this is
the
rate and then we can write all the
frames so we say object
dot
write frames
and we need to write this in binary so
we can create a binary string like this
so a string and then dot
join and here we put in our frames list
so this will combine
all the elements in our frames list into
a binary string and then we say object
dot close and this is everything we need
to do so now we can run python record
mic and test this
hi i'm patrick this is a test one two
three
and now it's done so here we have our
new file
so let's play this and see if this works
hi i'm patrick this is a test one two
three and it worked awesome and now as
last step i also want to show you how to
load mp3 files and not only wav files so
let's do this so to load mp3 files we
need an additional third party library
and i recommend to use piedup so this is
a very simple to use library it provides
a simple and easy high-level interface
to load and also to manipulate audio
so in order to install this we also need
to install ffmpeg
so on the mac i use homebrew so i had to
say brew install ffmpeg and after this
you can simply say pip install and then
piedup and now this should install it so
here it's already satisfied and now we
can for example say from
piedup we want to import the
audio segment
and then we can say audio equals audio
segment and then here we can say from
mp3 if we have an mp3 in my case right
now i only have a from wave and then
here i let's load the
um
patrick dot wave and then we can for
example also very easily manipulate this
by saying audio plus
six audio plus 6 so this will
increase
the volume
by
6
d
b
6 db then we can also for example repeat
the clip so we say audio equals
audio
times 2
then we can use a fade in for example
audio equals audio dot
um
fade
underscore in
with with 2
000 milliseconds so two seconds fade in
the same works with fade out so yeah
this is how we can manipulate and then
we can say audio dot
export and then i want to export this in
let's call this mesh up dot mp3 and then
i have to say format equals
as a string mp3 and now for example i
could load um this by saying
audio2 equals audio dot from
mp3 and then here i use
meshup dot mp3 and then print
done so that we see it arrives at this
part and now let's say python and then
the
load mp3 file
and yeah this works so now here we have
our mp3 file and we could also load it
like this so yeah that's how you can use
the python module to load other file
formats as well and that's all i wanted
to show you in this first part i hope
you learned a little bit about audio
processing in python and enjoyed this
and now let's move on and let's learn
how to do speech recognition in python
hey and welcome in this project we are
going to learn how to do speech
recognition in python it's going to be
very simple what we're going to do is to
take the audio file that we recorded in
the previous project and turn it into a
text file let me show you how the
project works so here is the audio file
that we recorded in the previous project
hi i'm patrick this is a test123
and if we run our script
we get the text transcription of this
audio file so like this here
hi i'm patrick this is a test123
so let's learn how to implement this in
python so for this project we are mainly
going to need two things assembly ai's
api to do the speech recognition and the
requests library from python to talk to
assembly ai's api so let's first go
ahead and get a api token from assembly
ai it's very simple you just need to go
to assemblyai.com and create a free
account once you have an account you can
sign in and just copy your api key just
by clicking here and right away i'm
going to create a configure file
and put my api key here
once i've done that now i have a way of
authenticating who i am with assembly is
api and now we can start setting up how
to upload transcribe and get the
transcription from assembly as api the
next thing that i want to do is to have
a main file that is going to have all my
code what i need to do in there is to
import the requests library so that i
can talk to the assembly ai api so this
project is going to have four steps the
first one is to upload the file that we
have locally to assembly ai second one
is to start the transcription third one
is keep polling assembly ai's api to see
when the transcription is done and
lastly we're going to save this
transcript
so uploading is actually quite simple if
we go to the documentation of assembly
ai
we will see here uploading local file
files for transcription so i can just
copy and paste this
and change the code as we need it so
basically yeah okay we are importing the
request library already um the file name
we're going to get from the terminal so
i will
set that later um
just a couple of things that we need to
pay attention here basically there is a
way to read the audio file from our file
system and then we need to set up a
headers and the setters are used for
authentication so we can actually
already set this because this is not
going to be your api token we set it to
be api key assembly ai right
and we need to import it here of course
all right that's done so we also have a
upload endpoint for assembly and this
one is api.assemblyai.com
v2 upload
but you know this might be something
that we need also later so i'm just
going to put this to a separate value
variable
and then just call this one here
so when we're doing uh when we're
uploading a file to assembly ai we are
doing a post request in this post
request you need to you need to send
this post request to the upload endpoint
you need to include your api key
included in the headers and of course
you need the data so the file that you
read and we are reading the data through
the read file function in chunks because
assembly ai requires it to be in chunks
and in chunk sizes of five megabytes
basically this is the number of bytes
that are in there while we're at it we
can already get the file name from the
terminal too right so for that i just
need to import system
and
inside system the second or the first
not the zeroth
variable or the argument is going to be
the file name
and here let's clean up a little bit
all right now we should be able to just
run a command on the terminal uh include
the name of the file that we want to
upload and it will be uploaded to
assembly ai and we will also let's print
the response um that we get from
assembly ai to see what kind of response
we get again this is the file that we
are working with
hi i'm patrick this is a test one two
three
and what we need to do right now is to
run python main.pi
and the name of the file in this case
output.12
all right so we uploaded our file to
assemble the ai successfully
and the response what we get is the
upload url so where your data where your
audio file lives right now and using
this we can start the transcription so
for the transcription let's again cheat
by getting the code from the docs here
is the data the code that we need
starting from here
so this is a transcription endpoint you
can see that it ends differently than
the upload endpoint this one ends with
upload this one ends with transcript i
will call this the transcript endpoint
um headers we already have a header we
don't really need this anymore uh the
end point is transcript endpoint
uh json is the data that we are sending
to
or the data that we want assembly ai to
transcribe so
we are going to need to give it the
audio url we already have the auto url
right so um we got the response but we
did not extract it from the response so
let's do that odo url
is response.json
and it was called
upload url
so we're going to give this audio url
to here because it was just an example
okay and this way we will have started a
transcription and uh let's do this and
see what the result is
i will run this again same thing
all right so we got a much longer
response in this response what we have
we have a bunch of information about the
transcription that we've just started so
you do not get the transcript itself
immediately because depending on the
length of your audio it might take a
minute or two right so um what we get
instead is the id of this transcription
job so by using this id from now on we
can ask assembly ai hey here is the id
of my job this transcription job that i
submitted to you is it ready or not and
if it's not ready it will tell you it's
not ready yet it's still processing if
it's ready it will tell you hey it's
completed and here is your transcript so
that's why the next thing that we want
to build is the polling we're going to
keep we're going to write the code that
will keep polling assembly ai to tell us
if the transcription is ready or not but
before we go further let me first clean
up this code a little bit so that you
know everything is nicely packed and
functions we can use them pre-use them
again if we need to so this one is the
upload function
yes and what it needs to return is the
audio url
we do not need to print the response
anymore we've already seen what it looks
like and we need to put the header
separately because we want
both upload and transcribe and basically
everything else to be able to reach this
variable called headers
for transcription again i will create a
function called transcribe
and what i need to return from the
transcription function
is the id so i will just say
job id
and that would be response.json
and id
again we don't need this anymore
i'll just call this transcript
response to make it clear this will be
upload
response
let's call this transcript request
so everything is nice and clean this is
this and this goes here
and for upload response we use it here
and we need to return job id
all right so now we have them nicely
wrapped up in different functions and
everything else looks good let's run
this again to see that it works
oh of course i'm not calling the
function so let me call the functions
and then run it
upload
and transcribe but of course i also need
to pass the file name to the upload
function
so let's do that too
url is not defined
audio of course then i also need to pass
audio url
audio url
to transcribe
good thing we tried
so this will be returned from the upload
function and then we will pass it to the
transcribe function
and as a result we will get
job id
and then i can print job id to see that
it worked
let's see
yes i do get a jaw body so okay things
are working the next thing that we want
to do is to set up the polling function
so the first thing we need to do for
that is to create a polling endpoint
pulling endpoint so as you know we have
the transcript endpoint and the upload
endpoint here um that's how we
communicate with assembly ai's api with
polling endpoint it's going to be
specific to the transcription job that
you just submitted so to create that all
you need to do is to combine
transcript endpoint
with a slash in between
and add the job id but the job id is a
bit awake so i'll just going to call
this transcript id
so by doing that now you have a url that
you can ask to assembly ai with which
you can ask assembly ai if your job is
done already or not
and again we're going to send a request
to assembly ai this time it's going to
be a get request but i'll just copy this
so that it's easy uh
instead of post it's going to be a get
request we're going to use the polling
endpoint instead of the transcript
endpoint and
we just need the headers for this we do
not because we are not sending any
information to assembly ai we're just
asking for information um if you're
familiar with requests normally this
might be very simple for you but all you
need to know about this is that when
you're sending data to an api you use
the post
request type and if you're only getting
some information as the name suggests
you use the get
request type so the result the resulting
or the response that we get is going to
be called polling response
um
let's see it's not job id i called
transcript id so that it works um then
we get the polling response and i can
also show you what the polling response
looks like
looks good okay let's run this
all right so the it we got response 200
that means things are going well but
actually what i need is a json response
so
let's see that again
yes this is more like it so again we get
the id of the response a language model
that is being used and some other bunch
of information but what we need here is
the status so let's see where that is
oh yeah there it is so we have status
processing um this means that the
transcription is still being is still
being prepared so we need to wait a
little bit more and we need to ask
assembly ai again soon to see if the
transcription is done or not what we
normally do is to wait 30 seconds or
maybe 60 seconds depending on the length
of your
transcription or length of your audio
file and then when it's done it will
give us status completed so let's write
the bit where we ask assembly ai
repetitively if the transcription is
done or not so for that we can just
create a very simple while loop
while true
we do the polling
and if
polling response dot json
status
equals to completed
we return the
polling
response
but
if polling
response
status is
error because it is possible that it
might error out
then we will return um
there
i'll just wrap this into a function i
can call this gets transcription
results url and while we're at it we
might as well also
wrap the polling into a
function
do we need to pass anything to it
yes the transcript id
we need to pass a transcript id to it
um
and instead of printing the response we
will just return the response
so instead of doing the request here all
we would need to do is to call this
function
with the transcript id
uh we can pass the transcript id here or
might as well i will just call the
transcription or transcribe function in
here
and the resulting
thing would be the transcript id from
the transcription function
and then i'm going to pass this
transcript id to the polling function
that is going to return to me the
polling response
uh i will call this polling response
data
and
inside this data so this is not needed
anymore
um
yeah just this
so the polling response.json is what is
being passed i call that the data so i
change this to data here and also
data here
um
yeah then i'll just pass the data
uh if it's error i can still pass the
data just to see the response and what
kind of what kind of error that we got
and hear them and just just say none
all right let's let's do a little
cleanup so we have a nice upload
function a transcribe function uh what
we did before was we were calling the
upload function getting the audio url
and then passing it to transcribe but
i'm running transcribe here so i do not
need this anymore i still need to pass
the audio url to transcribe so then i
would need to pass it to here so instead
of this
i just need to call
this function
with the audi url
um yeah let's put these here
actually to make it a bit more
understandable maybe instead of passing
the string error i can just pass
whatever error
that was that happened in my
um
transcription then you know we'll be
able to see what went wrong
all right so what we get as a result
from get transcription result id is the
data
and if there is any the error
so then let's why not run this and see
what the data is going to look like
all right so we get something really
really big let's see maybe i'll just
clear this and run it again just so that
you know we can see it more clearly
all right so we get the id again the
language model that is being used etc
now we want the results yes it is under
text uh hi i'm patrick this is a test
one two three is what we get and we also
get the breakdown of words uh when each
word started and then each word ended in
milliseconds confidence of this
classification
and much more information what we want
to do though even though we have all
this information we want to write this
transcript that is generated by assembly
ai into a text file so in this next step
that's what we're going to do
all right let's come up with a file name
for this file
uh we can call it actually we can just
call it the same thing as the file name
plus txt so the file name okay we were
using the
argument or variable file name too so
maybe let's find something else
i will just call this
text
file name
and it will be the file name
plus
dot txt uh we can also just you know
remove the dots valve or dot mp4 or
whatever but well let's not deal with
that for now
so once i have this i will just
open it
i will open it in writing format
and inside i will write data
text because that's where we have the
text information on the transcript if
you remember here this was a response we
got and text includes the transcription
and i can just prompt the user saying
that transcription is saved
transcription
saved
we're happy
of course there is a possibility that
our transcription errored out so you
want to cover that too if you remember
we returned data and error
what we can do is you can say if data is
returned
this happens
but if it errored out
i will just print
there
no
it didn't work out and the air itself so
that we see you know what went wrong
okay let's do a little cleanup again i
want to wrap this all up in a function
we can call the save transcript
[Music]
data
and error will be returned from get
transcript url
it needs the audio url so i will just
need to pass audio url here
and with that we're actually more or
less ready so let's run this and see if
we get what we need the transcript saved
in a file
for that after the after calling the
upload
function i can move this one
here and calling the upload function
here
called upload function and then i call
the save transcript function and
let's quickly follow that up um i call
the save transcript function it calls
get transcription result url get
transcription result url calls
transcribe transcribe is here
uh it starts the transcription process
and then
get transcription result url also calls
polling so it keeps pulling assembly ai
and when it's done it returns something
and then we deal with it in the safe
transcript function and we either save a
transcript or if there's an error we
display the error so uh let's run this
and see if we get any errors
transcription saved all right let's see
um
output valve.txt if i open it up
it looks quite small maybe i can if i
open it like this
yes hi i'm patrick this is a test one
two three is the result that we're
getting so that's awesome we actually
achieved what we wanted to do so in this
next couple of minutes i actually want
to clean up the code once again because
you're going to build a couple more
projects and we want to have a
python file that has some reusable code
so we don't have to reinvent the wheel
all the time
so let me first go here actually when
we're doing the pulling if we just have
the while true uh loop it's going to
keep asking assembly ai for results and
you know that that might be unnecessary
so what we can do is to include some
waiting times in between so it can ask
if it's not completed yet it can wait
let's say 30 seconds to ask again
so we can inform
the user
waiting 30 seconds
uh what i need is a time module
so this call is 30
and i will just import time here
and this way it should be waiting 30
seconds in between asking assembly ai if
the transcript is ready or not
and okay let's create that extra file
that we have api
communication i'll call it
um
yes so i will move all of the functions
that communicate with the api there so i
need to move the upload function
i need to move transcribe poll all of
these actually
so just remove that yeah
uh
let's see did we miss anything no i'll
just remove these from here
file name can stay here of course
headers and the upload and transcript
endpoints need to live here
because they are needed by the functions
in here we have to import the requests
library
so we don't need it anymore here
we need to import the
assembly ai api key
system needs to stay here time needs to
go there
and we also need to import from api
communication
import let's say all and that way we can
use this function in our main python
script
i will run this again to make sure that
it is still working so i will delete
the text file that was created i will
keep the output
nice so we also get the prompt that the
program is waiting 30 seconds before
asking again
oh yeah we passed the file name but of
course it might not exist there so let's
go and fix that the file name is here we
only pass it to the upload function and
the upload function is here now
um
and in the save transcript we do not
pass it but we are actually using it so
what we can do is to just also pass the
file name here
and that should be fine it should fix
the problem
transcription saved all right let's see
output 12.txt hi
um
[Music]
like this
hi i'm patrick this is a test123 so this
is a very short
audio file and we've actually been using
it over and over again so i want to also
show that this code is working to you
using another audio file
this is the audio of the one of the
latest short videos that i made for our
youtube channel
i was just talking about what natural
language processing is so this time
maybe if i add underscores it will be
easier
to call
yes
i'll just copy its name
and when i'm calling the script i will
use its name
this will probably take a little bit
longer because the audio file have you
been using is only a couple of seconds
and this one is one minute so we will
see what the results are going to show
us
right here we go the transcription is
saved we find it here
right this is exactly what i was talking
about
let's uh listen to it while the
transcription is open
can alexa be your best buddy well not
now but probably very soon we have been
seeing gigantic leaps over the last
couple of years in terms of how
computers can understand and use natural
language
all right you get the idea so our code
works this is amazing i hope you've been
able to follow along if you want to have
the code don't forget that you can go
get it and the github repository we
prepared for you using the link in the
description
welcome back to the third project so in
this one i teach you how to apply
sentiment analysis to youtube videos so
you will learn how to use the youtube dl
package to automatically download
youtube videos or only extract the
information you need and then i also
teach you how to apply sentiment
analysis so in this example i use iphone
30 review videos and the result that we
get looks like this so for each sentence
in the video we get the text and then we
also get the sentiment so this could be
positive negative or neutral for example
if we read this text here the new iphone
display is brighter than before the
battery life is longer and so on and the
sentiment is positive and here the text
is still there are some flaws and now
the sentiment is negative so this works
pretty well and this can be applied to
so many use cases so let's get started
and see how to do this so here i've
created a new project folder and we
already have our api secrets and the api
pi file with the helper functions to
work with the assembly ai api
and now let's create two more files so
the main.pi file that will combine
everything and the youtube extractor
files this is another helper file to
extract the infos from the youtube video
and for this we are going to use the
youtube dl package this is a very
popular command line program to download
videos from youtube and other sites and
we can use this as command line program
but we can also use this in python so
for this we say pip install youtube dl
and then we can import this so we say
import youtube dl and then we set up an
instance so we say ydl equals
youtube.youtubedl
[Music]
and now i'm going to show you how you
can download a video file and also how
you can extract the infos from a video
so let's create a helper function that i
call get
video
infos
and this takes an url
and now we use the ydl object as a
context manager so we say with ydl then
we say result equals ydl dot
extract info
and this gets the url and by default it
has download equals true so this would
also download the file
but in my case i say download equals
false
because of course we could download the
file and then upload it to assembly ai
but we can actually skip this step and
just extract the url of the hosted
file and then we can pass this to the
transcribe endpoint in assembly ai so we
can set download equals false here then
we do one more check so we say if
entries if the entries key is in the
result
then this means we have a playlist url
here and then we want to return only the
first video of this playlist
so we say return
result with the key
entries and then the
result zero or entry zero
and otherwise um we return the result
simply so this is the whole video info
object
and then let's create another helper
file that i call get
audio url and this gets the video infos
and first of all let's simply print all
the video infos to see how this looks
like
so now let's say if underscore name
equals equals main
and then let's first extract the video
info so video info equals get video
infos this needs an url
and then we say audio url equals
get
audio url and then we want to print the
audio url so right now this is none
because we don't return anything
so let's get an example
url so for this i went to youtube and
searched for iphone 13 review
and i choose this video so iphone 13
review pros and cons so we can click on
this and then we have to watch an ad but
we can actually
copy this url right away
and then put it in here as a string and
now if we run this
then so we run
pythonyoutubeextractor.com
then it should print the
um whole
url so yeah actually here i have to pass
this youtube info
and let's try this again
and yeah so here it extracted the whole
or it printed the whole info so this is
actually a very
long object a very long dictionary
so i can tell you that this has a key in
it that is called
formats
so let's actually print only the formats
and if we run this then this is also
still a very large um
very large dictionary
but then again this is an inner
dictionary and this has a key that is
called um
or actually this is a list
so now we can iterate over this so here
we say
four f in video in for formats
and then we can print the
f let's print f dot
and it has the key x for extension
and it also has a url so we also want to
print
f dot u r l
and now if we run this then let's see
what happens
um
let's actually
comment out the url because this is
super long so
let's print only the extension
and now we see um we have a lot of
different extensions because it
actually start the video in a lot of
different formats and with a lot of
different
resolutions and so on
so
what we want is this one so the m4a this
is a audio format ending
so
we now check
if
the
format
if the extension
equals equals
m for
a
then we
return
the
f
url key so this is the audio url and if
we save this and then print this at the
very end then we should get the url to
this hosted
file
so
you can see this is at this url so this
is uh not related to youtube.com so now
let's for example click on this
and
then
we have this in our browser so we could
listen to the audio file
so yeah this is the first part how to
work with the youtube dl package to
extract the infos and now let's combine
this in the main.pi so in main.pi we
combine the youtube extractor infos with
assembly ai and extract the transcript
of the video and also the sentiment
classification results
so sentiment classification is usually a
pretty difficult task but assembly ai
makes it super simple to apply this so
if we go to the website assemblyi.com
and have a look at the features then we
see they provide core transcription so
this is basically the speech recognition
we've seen in the last part but they
also offer audio intelligence features
and they are pretty cool so there are a
lot of features you can use for example
detect important phrases and words topic
detection auto chapters so auto
summaries and much more and if we scroll
down then here we find sentiment
analysis
so if we click on this then we see a
short description so with sentiment
analysis assembly ai can detect the
sentiment of each sentence of speech
spoken in your audio files
sentiment analysis returns a result of
positive negative or neutral for each
sentence in the transcript so this is
exactly what we need here and it's
actually super simple to use this so the
only thing we have to change is when we
call the transcript endpoint we also
have to send sentiment analysis equals
true as json data so this is all we need
to do
so let's go to our code and implement
this so let's import all the files we
need so we want json then we say from
youtube extractor we import get audio
url and get video infos and from our api
helper file we import save transcripts
then here i create one helper function
that i call safe video
sentiments and this gets the url and
here we get the video
infos by calling
get video infos with the url
then we get the audio url by calling get
all your url and this gets the video
infos
and then i simply call the safe
transcript function and this gets the
audio url and it also gets a title
and for the title i want to use the
title of the video so we can get this
from the video infos so this has a key
that is called title and then i want to
slightly modify this so i say title
equals
title dot strip so i want to remove all
leading and trailing white space
and then i want to replace all spaces
with a underscore and then i also say
title
equals
data slash
plus
title
so i want to store this in a separate
folder so here we create this and call
this
data
and now we have to modify this slightly
so if we have a look back
then we see this needs the additional
argument sentiment analysis
and now so in the
safe transcript file i will put this as
additional argument
and i will give this a default of false
and then here we say sentiment analysis
equals true
and now we have to
pass this
through
so we have to pass this to the get
transcription result url so this also
needs this parameter then the transcribe
needs the parameter
and here this needs the parameter and
now
as a
json data that we send we put
sentiment analysis equals true or false
and this is all that we need
and now of course i also want to
save this
so here we check if the
parameter is true
then i create a separate file so again i
say file name equals title plus
and then let's call this underscore sent
to
mance.json
and
now i say with
with
open the file name
in right mode
s f and then i import json in the top
import json
and then here we simply say json
dot
dump
and first we have to extract the infos
of course so we call this
sentiments equals
data and then the key
if we have a look at the documentation
then here we see that json response now
has this additional key
sentiment analysis results
so we use this and then we dump the
sentiments
into the file and i also want to say
indent equals four
to make this a little bit more readable
and now in the main.pie we call this
function and say if underscore name
equals equals underscore main
and then i want to call the save video
sentiments
and the url is this one so let's copy
and paste this in here
and now let's run the main.pi file and
hope that everything works
so the website is downloaded and
transcription starts so this looks good
so let's wait all right so this was
successful and the transcript was saved
and now we have a look at the data
folder then here we get the transcript
of the video and we also see our json
file with all the sentiments
so for each sentiment we get the the
text of the sentence so for example this
one with the exception of a smaller
notch the iphone 30 doesn't seem very
new at first glance but when you start
using this flagship you start to
appreciate a bunch of welcome upgrades
then we get the start and end time then
we get the sentiment which is positive
and we also get the confidence which is
pretty high then the next example the
new iphone display is brighter than
before the battery life is longer and
apple has improved blah blah blah so
here also the sentiment is positive
then we have still there are some flaws
here and now the sentiment is negative
so this works pretty well and yeah this
is how you can apply sentiment analysis
with assembly ai now i want to show you
a little bit more code how we could
analyze this for example
so now we can comment this out so we
don't need to download this again
then we can read our json file and here
we store the positives negatives and
neutrals so we iterate over the data and
then we extract the text so the text and
we also extract the sentiment so then we
check if this is positive negative or
neutral and append it to the
corresponding list
then we can calculate the length of each
list and then we can print the number of
positives negatives and neutrals and we
can also for example calculate the
positive ratio
so here we ignore the neutrals and
simply do the number of positives
divided by the number of positives plus
the number of negatives and now if we
save this and run this again
then here we get the number of positives
so 38 only four negatives over all
positive ratio is 90
so with this you can get a pretty quick
overview of a review for example
and yeah i think the sentiment
classification feature can be applied to
so many different use cases it's so cool
so yeah i hope you really enjoyed this
project and now what would be really
cool is if we could display these
information in a nice looking web app
and this is actually one thing that you
will learn in the next tutorial together
with misra so let's move on to the next
project
all right now it's time to build a
podcast summarization app and we're also
going to build a web interface for this
application in this project we are again
going to use assembly ai's api that
offers the chapterization summarization
features and we are going to get the
podcast from the listen notes api so
let's get into it here is what our app
is going to look like once we are done
with it so we will get a episode id from
listen notes api i will show you how to
do that and when we click this button it
will give us the first the title of the
podcast and an image the name of the
episode and then we will be able to see
different chapters and when they start
in this episode and if we click these
expanders we will be able to read a
summary of the chapter of this episode
this is all quite exciting to start
building a web front end for our
application too so let's start building
it so in this project like in the
previous ones we are going to have a
main script and we are going to have a
supporting script api communication
where we have all of our supporting
functions that we want to use over and
over again we built this before so this
is the exact same one from the third
project the project that we did before
um
and we will only need to update this and
change some things to start doing
podcast summarization but the first
thing that i want to update here is that
we will not actually need the upload
endpoint anymore so i'm just going to go
ahead and delete that one because um the
transcripts are going to be or sorry the
podcasts are going to be received from
the listen notes api so it's going to be
somewhere on the internet we will not
download them to our own computer so we
can immediately
tell assembly ai hey here's the audio
file here is the
address of the audio file that i want
you to transcribe and it will be able to
do that so there will be no download or
upload needed
that's why i also don't need the upload
function
also the chunk size not relevant anymore
all right so that's good for now and the
next thing that we want to do is to set
up the listen notes api communication so
we are going to use assembly ai to
create the summaries of the podcast and
we will get these podcasts from listen
notes if you've never heard of it before
listen notes is basically a database of
podcasts i think nearly all of the
podcasts so you can search for any
podcast for example one of my favorites
is 99 invisible
and you will be able to get all of its
information plus the episodes so you can
search for episodes here if you would
like to
uh what we're going to do with listen
notes is that we are going to send it a
episode id a specific episode id that we
will find on um the platform itself so
let's say i want to get the latest
episode of 99 invisible if i go to the
episode page
and go down to use api to fetch this
episode
i will see a id so this is the id of the
specific id of this episode and using
this id i will be able to get this
episode and send it to assembly ai and
this is exactly the id that we need on
our application
so um to get that first of course we
need the listen notes endpoint listen
note has a bunch of different endpoints
but the one that we need is the episode
endpoint to get the episode information
so i will just name this listen notes
episode
endpoint and it is this one and of
course we also need the header again to
authenticate ourselves and in the header
we're going to need to put a api key so
all you have to do is go to listen notes
create an account and get an api key for
yourself and we are going to go and
paste it here
and here as you know we are importing
the api key for assembly ai now i'm also
going to
import the api key for listen notes and
we are going to send it
with our requests
to listen notes so i'll call this the
listen notes headers
and this is the assembly ai headers
and for listen knows this is named x
listen api key
all right
the first thing that i want to do is to
build a new function that is able to get
the episode id and give us the url to
the podcast's audio file so i will call
this one
get
episode
audio
url
and it is going to get an episode id
and we're going to send a get request to
listen notes
let's build the url first
the url is going to consist of the
listen notes episode endpoint
and
a dash
plus the episode id
and we are going to
send
a get request
to this url i will call the response we
get response for now
and the last thing that we need of
course is the headers for authentication
and that one is called listen notes
headers so after we do this we should be
able to get a url for the episode id and
the information
is going to be sent us in the json
format so this way we'll be able to see
it so maybe uh
let's try this at first and see that it
works so to do that i am just going to
again import
from api communications
import everything i'll just make this a
simple python script for now and i'm
going to call get episode audio url
um and i will use the
episode id that i found here
this one to keep things simple and
as a result we will print the
response that we get from listen note so
let's run this and see what happens
all right this is a really long so maybe
i'll i will use a pretty print
to make it more readable so this
pretty print here
and instead of this
just use pretty print
okay let's do it again
all right
that is slightly better
let's see what kind of information we
are working with
um nice we get the audio url here this
is the url of the audio let's see where
that takes us
yeah this is just the audio of this
podcast you can hear it
porosity that the roman advance was
halted
nice
all right so this is exactly what we
need but if you want you can also get
some extra information about the podcast
if you want to display it in some way we
will definitely just display it this is
a description of the episode whether
there is explicit content or not um the
image of this episode
uh and some extra information about the
podcast like facebook handle google
handle etc so you get a lot of
information so if you want to make your
web application and your interface even
more interesting more interactive you
can of course include more of this in
your application so if we just return
data audio from here we will actually
just return the audio url but you know
now that we have all this information
might as well extract some more of it so
some of the things that we can get as a
thumbnail of this episode um name of the
podcast and title of this episode for
example like we said we will display
here
so let's do that
this will be the audio url we will also
get the episode thumbnail
thumbnail
we can get the podcast title
that would be in podcasts
and then podcast specific information
and then we get the title
and lastly episode title
i think it is just title
and we can just pass all of this
information back
episode
thumbnail
episode title
and podcast
title so we don't really need to change
much from the rest of the functions for
example transcribe poll get
transcription result that we already
built beforehand uh the only thing that
we need to change is now we're not going
to do sentiment analysis we need we want
to do use auto chapters features of
assembly ai so i am just going to rename
these to all the chapters this is just
the name of a variable so it is not that
important you can keep it the same
but for readability it's probably better
to change it to all the chapters but
here
in this variable we need to change
this name to auto chapters because we
are sending this request to assembly ai
and it needs to know that we want other
chapters
what else we also just updated the name
of the header so it's not only headers
now it's assembly ai headers
same here um
and the polling we do not need to change
anything we are only asking if the
transcription is done or not
again in get transcription result url we
want to change it to other chapters
one other thing that i want to change is
it's a very small but normally we were
waiting for 30 seconds but now i want to
wait for 60 seconds because podcast
episodes tend to be a little bit longer
so we want to wait a little bit longer
in between asking assembly ai if the
transcription is ready or not this is
another change but the main work is
going to happen in the save transcript
function so the main change we're going
to need to do in save transcript
function is that before we were
uploading our audio to assembly ai and
then we were getting the result back but
instead this time we are going to
only have a episode id and then we are
going to get the url from listen notes
and then we are going to pass that to
assembly ai to start the transcription
uh so
what i want to do here is to instead of
url and title i will just
give save transcript the episode id and
then i will run the get episode audio
url
from
oops from inside the save transcript
and as a result
what we're getting is order url episode
thumbnail episode title and podcast
title
again we are not doing sentiment
analysis we are doing order chapters
and we need to pass the order url
to get transcription result url um get
transcription result url gets um the
order url as url and other chapters but
it is not defined so
you know this is what we want to do so
let's just call it a true here
um
the next thing that we want to do is to
deal with the response that we get from
assembly ai so let's first see what the
response from assembly ai looks like
when we're doing auto chapters and then
let's deal with it
but let's fix some of the problems here
so i will not save it into a file for
now
i can comment these out
this will be other chapters
the main thing that i want to do is
see what the result looks like right so
i will pretty print
the data
and the data is already in json format
um
transcribe
yes it
is
yeah so i will just uh
show that so i'm just going to comment
these out for now just so that you know
we have an idea of what the response
looks like
to run this
i
will just pass
the episode id to
save transcript
oh we're still printing
um this one so i will
actually stop printing the response from
listen notes
let's start it again
all right so we got the results
let's see what it looks like
it's a lot of information let's scroll
to the top
and what we wanted was the chapters
basically so let's see what the chapter
information includes so as you can see
this is one chapter
and this is another chapter so for each
chapter we have the starting point and
then we have the ending point the gist
of the chapter so really quickly what is
this chapter about
we have a headline for this chapter and
a summary so in a couple of sentences
what is happening in this chapter what
what is the presenter talking about what
we want to do is to
show this information on our application
right on our web interface so that's why
what we want right now is to extract
this information from
the response we get from assembly ai and
then save it somewhere and then we can
visualize it on our stream that
application
so i will undo the commenting here
also here
so i will call this file
with the episode
id it will be episode id dot txt
and as we always do i i'm just going to
save the transcript you know we don't
have to touch this so much but i will
start another
file
and
let's call this
chapters file name
and this one will be episode
id
plus
maybe let's call like chapters.txt
all right so the chapters
will be another file so i'm going to
keep all the chapter information
somewhere else
and in here i'm going to write some of
the information i got from assembly ai
specifically chapter information and i'm
also going to include some of the
information i got from the listen notes
api uh
one mistake here i do not want it to be
a text file i want it to be a json file
so that it will be easier to parse
easier to read later for me the first
thing that i want is the chapters and
i'm going to get that from the data
variable
it's called chapters so let's check
this section is called chapters yeah
so let's start it i will say episode
data
at first let's include the chapters
again i will call it chapters
and then inside this episode data
what do i want i want the episode
thumbnail
i want the episode title
and i want the podcast title
so that i have all of this information
in one place saved on my file system i
can just read it whenever i want and
display to the user
and finally dump that
to the file
episode
data
and i'll let the
user know that the transcript is saved
this part we don't need anymore
and again if there's an error we will
just say that there is an error
and we will return true
now that we've got this far ready up
till now what we do is get the url from
based on the episode id from listen
notes and then send it to this url to
assemble the ai gets audio chapters
information
and then save it to a file so
let's see that this works well and while
it's running we will start the streamled
application
so i will just run this again
but in the main
we of course need to
call safe transcript okay we're already
doing it so i will just
run the application and let's also start
building our stream with application now
so if you've never heard of streamlit
before it is a really easy way to start
building web interfaces for your
application specifically for python it's
very simple to use it is has a very
simple api it's a very simple library so
what you have to do is you call you
import streamlet
as sd if you wanted to use it simply
and let's say if you want to um you know
put a title in your application all you
need to do is sd title and then
you can show that it is a title so i
will run this separately
to show you how it works
and to runs from the applications you
just need to say extremely run main the
pi um stream it is
installed on your computer like any
other python library so you just need to
use pip
say pip install streamlet and you will
be good to go
unless you make a mistake and call
stream with a capital s
which is not the case it needs to be a
lowercase s so let's do that again
all right so this is actually an
application it's the only thing we're
showing right now is a title and we know
what you want it to look like is this so
i will start building the um elements of
in this application so the first thing
that you know strikes us is that we have
a sidebar we have a title that says
podcast summaries and then we start
showing the information from the um
information we got from the apis that
we've been using
so
let's put a sidebar maybe let's let's
fix the title first we want to say
podcast summaries
title says podcast summaries
i can even say welcome
to our
to my application
that
creates
podcast summaries
let's see maybe that will be too long
but we'll see
and let's create the sidebar it's quite
simple you call
streamlet sidebar dot text
input yeah
and then you know you can say please
input a
and episode id
and i can also have a button at the end
of the sidebar
that says
get
um podcast
summary
maybe with the exclamation point too
so let's run it again
okay this is looking more like it it
says welcome to my application that
creates podcast summaries um i can put
an episode id here and then i can say
get podcast summary so you see that it
is running it is running because i
forgot to
comment out this one so it's actually
running the whole application i'll just
stop it for now because we don't have
any way of displaying whatever we get
back from
the apis
so i'll stop this now and now that we
have the application looking more or
less like what we want it to look like
let's wait for
the chapter results to be printed on our
file and then we will see what it looks
like and then we can start parsing it
and then showing it to the user on our
streamled application okay so the
transcription is saved our auto chapter
creation is done
let's
take a look at what it looks like
we have the chapters section we have the
episode thumbnail episode title and
podcast title
um
[Music]
all good in the chapters we have chapter
numbers and inside each chapter we have
the summary headline just start
and end so it looks good let's start
showing this uh the first thing that i
want to show of course like we did in
the
beginning like we showed in the
beginning is the
name of the episode
or maybe name of the podcast plus the
name of the episode and then the episode
thumbnail so how i'm going to show that
is again using streamlet
and that is going to be the header for
me
and
i will include
the
podcast title
maybe the dash in between and the
episode title but as you can see we do
not have it yet so first we need to open
the file that includes these things and
the file that includes those things is
the episode id that underscore chapters
at jason
so let's start it again uh file name
would be episode
id
uh underscore
chapters.json and where do i get the
episode id
i get the episode id from the text input
so the user is going to import an
episode id and then i'm going to save it
here in this variable and that way i
will have the file name
so then i just need to open this file
and let's call it
data for example i need to import json
of course
and load it into the variable
data
so in this variable data what do we have
we have the chapters so first let's get
the chapters
data chapters
and then what we want to get is the
podcast title
and then the episode title
let's change the names episode title and
we also want the thumbnail
um and what did we call the thumbnail we
can see here uh episode thumbnail
all right
episode
thumbnail
so we're already showing the
podcast title and episode title stream
with header and then we can show the
image
uh thumbnail
about the streamlet image
function
and from this point on the next thing
that we want to show is the chapters of
course
one thing we can do is for example we
can use a for loop i could say for
chap in
chapters
um
you know you can just say streamlet
write
or just show the chop but that's one way
of doing it but then you're going to
have a lot of text one after another and
it's not really nice what we want is
like in the original one i showed you at
the beginning we want expanders so it's
quite easy to create expanders with
stream again you just say streamlet
expander and then you want you write
what kind of information you want
to be in your expander
so as the title of the expender
i will write here what i want in title
and
whatever i want inside the expender i'm
going to write inside so i do not need
to use a streamlet thing again because
this is going to be inside the expender
and inside the expander what i want is
the
summary so i think it was called summary
let's just check again here in our json
file in chapters we have summaries
called summary yes so i want the summary
to be in there and as a title of the
expander i want there to be the gist
of each chapter so for each chapter it's
going to show me
um the expanders for each chapter there
will be expanders and the title of the
expander will be the gist of this
chapter and inside the expander we are
going to have the summary of this
chapter so let's run this and see how it
looks but let's let's first make sure
that everything works so i have the
title and then i ask for a episode id
from the user
um there is a button
that starts this process
and for that to happen i'll just
call this button so we this information
this button uh variable has information
of whether this button has been pressed
or not and i only want this part this
part to happen this visualization
display part to happen if the button has
been pressed so i'm going to wrap this
all in a condition so otherwise it's not
going to happen
yes but right now if someone presses the
button nothing really happens so we also
need to add an action to this button and
how we're going to do that is we're
going to say on click
if this button is clicked what we want
to happen is
the save transcript file to be run
so i'm going to call it here
in the onclick argument and we also have
arguments right
and here is how you pass arguments
to your function that you call from your
button this is a tuple that's why you
write the variable or the argument that
you're passing to the function and the
first one and the second one is
empty uh now when the button is clicked
this one should run and we should be
able to see all the information on our
application so let's run it again and
see what happens
yeah we need to
run the streamlight application this
time streamlight run main.pi
i'll close the old ones so we know the
difference and which one is which
this is just the example from the
beginning all right
so
we want to get a podcast and we want to
display it
uh i will get this one again
let's get the podcast summary
and here it is uh we have the title
welcome to my application that creates
podcast summaries okay maybe that's a
bit too long i will shorten it
the name of the podcast name of the
episode number of the episode also the
missing middle and here are my chapters
so apparently there are one two three
four five six seven chapters assembly
ai's api was able to um find and in each
chapter we have the gist of the chapter
as a title of the expander and the
chapter summary here
one last thing that i want to add is the
start and end point of the or just the
start point of the chapter here because
i want to show like how long a chapter
is maybe so let's do that so for that i
want to see
in this json file how it looks so the
start looks like this so these numbers
might look a bit random to you but
basically they are milliseconds so i
want to turn it into
um minutes and seconds and if applicable
hours minutes and seconds and
there is already a function that can do
that here it is we don't need to you
know work on it for a long time
basically
you get the milliseconds and when you
get the milliseconds you can get the
seconds uh out of it how many seconds
there are how many minutes there are and
how many hours are so basically you're
counting the hours and everything
that is on top of the hour is
mentioned as a minute if it doesn't add
up to an hour and everything that does
not add up to a minute is
pointed out as seconds and here is what
we will return so we'll say start time
is either hours minutes and seconds and
if there is no hours we don't have to
say zero something something so just
show minutes and then seconds and how
i'm going to show it is within the
expander title
and i can you know show it with a dash
in between
i'll say get clean time
and in there what i want is a chapter
start let's see what it was
uh it just just start okay
all right let's run it one more time and
then see what our application looks like
awesome okay this is our application on
the sidebar we can input a episode id
that we get from listen notes we can say
get podcast summary
it will show a nice title title of the
podcast title of the episode show us a
thumbnail of this episode and for each
chapter we showed the gist of the
chapter kind of like a headline
when this chapter started and when you
click the expander when you expand it
you get the summary of this chapter so
this is what we set out to do when we
achieved it i hope you were able to
follow along again don't forget to go
grab the code from the github repository
welcome to the final project in this one
you will learn a bunch of new exciting
technologies first of all you will learn
how to do real time speech recognition
in python then you will learn how to use
the openai api and build a virtual
assistant or chatbot and finally you
will learn a little bit about websockets
and how to use async io in python so i
think this is going to be really fun and
first of all let me show you the final
project so now when i run the code i can
start talking to my bot and ask
questions
what's your name
how old are
you what's the best ice cream
and you see this works so i think this
is super exciting so now let's get
started alright so here i have a new
project folder and again we have our api
secrets file and now a new main.pi file
and the first thing we're going to do is
set up real-time speech recognition and
for this we have a detailed blog post on
the assembly ai block this will walk you
through this step by step
so first of all we need pi audio to do
the microphone recording so this is the
very same thing that we learned in part
one then we use web sockets and then we
use the assembly ai real-time speech
recognition feature that works over web
sockets and then we create a function to
send the data from our microphone
recording and also a function to receive
the data and then we can do whatever we
want with this
so
but in order to just copy and paste this
let's actually code this together so
let's get started um one note here in
order to use the real-time feature you
need to upgrade your account though so
yeah but anyway let's get started so
let's import all the things we need so
we want um pi audio again
then we need
websockets so we say import websockets
and this is a third-party library that i
showed you in the beginning that makes
it easy to work with websockets
and this is built on top of async i o so
now we're going to you to build async
code then we also import async io we
also import base64 so we need to encode
the data to a base64 string before we
send this
and then we import json to receive the
json result
and then we say from api secrets we
import our api key from assembly ai
and now the first thing we set up is set
up our microphone recording so for this
we use the exact same code that we
learned in part one so i simply copy and
paste this part from here
so let's copy and paste um so we
set up our parameters then our pi audio
instance and then we create our stream
and now we need to define the url for
the websocket
and we can find this on the
blog post home page so here i can copy
and paste the url
so the url is at websockets and then
assembly ai.com and then real time and
then the last part is also important so
here we say question mark sample rate
equals sixteen thousand so this is the
same rate that we use here so make sure
to align this with what you have and now
we create one function to send and
receive the data and this is a async
function so we say async def and we call
the send receive so this is responsible
for both sending and receiving the data
and now we connect to the websocket and
we do this with a async context manager
so again we say async and then width and
then websockets
dot
connect and now we specify the
parameters url then we say a we set a
ping
timeout
and we can set this to 20 for example
then we want a ping
interval and this should be five and
then we also need to send our
authorization token
so the key or the parameter for this is
extra
headers
and this is a dictionary with the key
authorization
and the value is our token
and then we say async with s and then we
can call this what we want so i say
underscore w s for websocket then first
we
wait to let this connect so here we say
await
async i o a sync i o dot
sleep 0.1 so be careful here we cannot
use time with sleep so we are inside a
async function so we have to use the
async sleep function
and then we
wait or we we try to connect and wait
for the result
so
we say
session underscore begins equals and
then again a weight underscore w s
and then this is called r e s v for
receive i guess
and then we can print the data and see
how this looks
let's also print um
sending
messages
and now um we need two
inner functions so again a async
function so we say async def sent
and for now we simply say pass
and then we say async def
receive and here also we pass
and actually these are both
these both will have a infinite while
true loop so they will run infinitely
and listen for
incoming data
so
here we say while true
and for now let's just print um sending
and here we also say while
true and here we simply pass so i don't
want to
spoil our output
and
now after this we need to combine them
in a
async i always so in order to do this
we say um
we call the gather function so it's
called async io dot
gather
and
now here we gather send and
receive
and this will return two things so the
send
result
and the
receive
results so actually we don't need this
but just in case we have this here
and
now
um after defining this function of
course we also have to
run the code and we have to run this in
an infinite loop
and in order to do this we call
async io and then dot run and then our
send receive function
so um
now
this should
connect and then should print sending
all the time
so let's run this and hope that this
works
so yeah it's already connected and
sending works so you see that's why i
didn't put the receive in here as well
so we get a lot of outputs and yeah i
can't even scroll to the top anymore but
basically yeah it should have printed
this once and then
now this is working so far so we can
continue implementing these two
functions now so now let's implement the
send function first and we wrap this in
a try accept block and now we read the
microphone input so we say stream dot
reads and then we specify the frames per
buffer and i also want to say exception
on overflow equals false so sometimes
when the websocket connection is too
slow there might be an overflow and then
we have an exception but i don't want
this
it should still work
and then we need to
convert this or encode it in base 64. so
we say
base64 b64
encode our data and then we decode it
again in utf-8
this is what assembly ai expects
then we need to convert it to a json
object so we say json dump s and then
this is a dictionary with the key
audio data so again this is what
assembly ai needs and then here we put
in the data and then we send this and we
also have to await this so awaits ws
sends the
json data
and then we have to
catch a few errors so let's copy this
from our blog post
so
these ones let's copy
and
paste this in here
so
um
we accept a web sockets exceptions
connection closed error then we print
the error then we make sure it's of this
code and then we also break and then we
catch every other error so it's not best
practice to do it like this but it's
fine for this simple tutorial
and then we assert here and then after
each while true iteration we also sleep
again
and yeah so now we can copy
this whole code and paste it into this
so the code is very similar here
um so we have the same try except but
now here of course we have to wait for
the transcription result from assembly
ai
so we say result
string
equals and then again we
wait and then the w s r e s v
then we can convert this to a dictionary
by saying results equals json dot
load from a string and here the result
string and now this has a few so this is
a json object or now in python it's a
dictionary so now we can
check a few
keys so we can get the prompt or
actually now this is the transcription
of what we set so we say prompt equals
results and then a test the key
text
and it also has a key that is called
message type
so now we check if we have a prompt
and
if the results and then the key
message underscore
type
and now um
this should be
final
transcript
and
now what assembly ai is doing it will
while we are talking it will already
start sending the transcript and once we
finished our sentence it will do another
pass and make a few small corrections if
necessary
and then we get the final transcript so
we want only the final transcripts and
now for now let's print
um
me and then let's print the
prompt
and now we want to use our chat bot so
now let's print um
bot
and then let's for now let's simply
print
um let's print a random text for now and
then we set up this in the next step but
first i want to
test this so let's say this is my
answer
and this is all that we need for the
receive functions so
let's
clear this and run this and test this
oh we get an error a weight wasn't used
with future async io gather oh this is a
classic mistake of course here i have to
say await async io gather
so
let's run this again
and now it's working
so
yeah
what's your name
and you see the transcript is working so
now i
stopped this but if i scroll up what's
your name and each time we get this is
my answer
so this is working and now of course
here we want to
do a clever thing with our prompt and
use our virtual assistant
so for this we now set up open ai so
they have a
api
that provides access to gpt-3
and this can perform a wide variety of
natural language tasks
so
in order to use this you have to sign up
but you can do this for free and you get
a free you get free credits so this will
be more than enough to play around with
this
and it's actually super simple to set
this up so
let's create a new file
and i call this um let's call this open
a i
helper dot pi
and then we also have to install this so
we have to say pip install open ai
[Music]
and then we also after signing up you
get a api token
so we have to copy this in api secrets
and then we can use this
and now we can import open ai and we
also need to import our secret so from
api secrets we import our api key open
ai then we have to set this so we say
open a i dot api key equals um
api key
and now we want to do question answering
so the the open ai api is actually super
simple to use
so we can click on examples
and then we see a bunch of different
examples so open ai can do a lot of
things for example q and a grammar
correction text to command
classification a lot of different stuff
so let's click on
q and a and if we scroll down then here
we find the code example so we already
set our api key and now we need to grab
this
and
let's
copy this and let's create a helper
function so define
and let's call this ask
computer and this gets the prompt as
input and now i paste this in here
so we say response equals open a i dot
complete
then here we specify an engine
and now we specify the
prompt and in our case the prompt is
going to be
the prompt that we put in so prompt
equals prompt
from the parameter and now there are a
lot of other different parameters that
you could check out in the documentation
so in my case i only want to keep the
max token so this will specify how long
the result can be
and yeah let's say 100 is fine for this
and now this is all that we need
and now of course we need to
um
return the response and this is actually
a json object again or now a dictionary
and we only want to extract the first
possible response
so it can also send more if you specify
this here
so in our case we only get one
and then we say response and this is in
the key um choices and then the index
zero so the first choice
and then the key text so this will be
the actual response from gpt3
and now in the main the only thing we
have to do is say from
open ai helper we import ask
computer
and then down here in the receive
functions and now here we say
um
response equals ask
computer and then we put in the
prompt and then here
this will be our response
and now this should be
everything that we need so now let's
again clear this and run the main.pie
and let's hope this works
what's your name
what's your name
how old are you
where are you from
all right so let's stop this again and
yeah you see this works and this is how
you can build a virtual assistant that
works with real time speech recognition
together with open ai and yeah i really
hope you enjoyed this project if you've
watched this far thank you so much for
following along and also i hope to see
you in the future on the assembly ai
channel because on there we also create
a lot of content around python speech
recognition and also machine learning so
please check it out and then i hope to
see you soon bye